- J, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Originally, Ohio, Cincinnati.
I was born and then ended
up in Indiana and in 2008
I ended up here in Skid Row.
- Why did you come out here to Skid Row?
- Because there wasn't no
resources where I came from.
I ran out of resources.
The economy was low.
And so I found this place
on the internet actually
and came out here with my tax returns.
- Tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
growing up as a kid.
- Yeah, it was a pretty typical family.
I was well taken care of up
until about my teenage years,
about 14 I moved out and it
was up and down since then.
- How would you describe your childhood?
- Family-wise I was well taken care of
but growing up socially, it
was, I was very backward.
I had a speech impediment,
a learning disability
also just being who, the
kind of person that I am a
I was always, pushed
aside or a zeroed out.
- Was there a certain point
where you became transgender
or do you think you've
always been this way?
- Yeah, since I can remember, yeah.
Kindergarden.
- Correct.
- So you always knew this
was your orientation?
- Yeah. Kindergarden I got
my first kiss on the leg
and butterflies, it's
been all downhill since.
- It's been downhill?
- Yeah. Jokingly, but yeah.
- And your life out here when I met you,
you were living on the street, right?
- Yeah.
- When I met you about
seven, eight years ago
you were living on the street.
- Yeah, I was there for seven years.
I met somebody.
He started running a
resource center, nonprofit
and I started it with him.
- You have housing now?
You're you're in an apartment on Skid Row.
- I got it in 2013.
Has been quite horrid.
I guess we don't realize it
but we become accustomed to some things.
And ever since I got the
housing, it's been hard.
cause I got so adjusted
to the outside and all
the activity around me.
But so it's made it just
been a little harder.
- That's interesting.
So there's an adjustment from, to go
from living on the street
to living an apartment.
- Yeah.
I thought it would be
awesome, but it's been rough.
- What was hard about that transition?
- Being alone.
Just like spiritually,
I've been going through
a lot of things and-
- Yeah, the street life is very social.
- Yeah.
- There's people all over
the streets all the time.
- Yeah.
And you're always, there's
always some kind of
you're always looking
around, there's always
something's stimulating
but once you get inside
and closed the doors and you're all alone
it's like everything closes in on you.
You have to learn to deal
with yourself a little more.
- And how do you support yourself?
Or how have you supported
yourself over the years?
When I first met you I think
you were dating guys, right?
- Yeah.
- Do you still do that?
- What was that?
- You still do that?
- Yeah.
Dating?
- No I don't anymore.
I'm on disability for my mental.
- What's your mental condition?
- I have psychosis and depression,
anorexia and transgender dysphoria.
For some reason they consider
that a disability, I don't
but I got an SSTI in 2013
which has been been a big
blessing because you can't depend
on nobody out here
You gotta find the hussle yourself.
And me coming from a small town,
it was a big culture shock.
Cause everything is so
busy and it's so fast
and I'm just standing there
dumbfounded on everything.
- Have you had bad things
happen to you here?
Being transgender do you get picked out?
- Yes a lot.
But the whole overall majority
is very more just well welcoming of it.
- It's more accepted here right?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Than it would be in Indiana.
- Very different.
I was in shock.
I mean, people don't even blink an eye
and just call you she
and it's a big shock from where I'm from.
You had to pry their teeth
out to let them know,
look, this ain't cool but
you still have to watch
your back out here.
There's a lot of deceiving
people, which is scary because I
had to learn the hard way
how deceiving people can be.
I'm not saying they're bad people, but
there's a survival program out here.
You just gotta learn to respect everybody
and keep on your side of
the road and keep pushing
and usually it's pretty cool.
- What's been the most
important lesson you've learned
since you came out to California
- Improvising.
And even though sometimes
people don't act like
the community's important because
as a whole is what makes us Skid Row.
But a lot of times we push
through every day just
trying to make it and not realizing that.
But when it comes down
to it, there's usually
somebody you can depend on
to get through something.
- And do you have friends?
- Yeah a few in my housing.
Like I said it's been a big adjustment.
I think I have a big trust
issue with a lot of people.
So my mind wants to be,
you want to be, you know
living this fantasy life
but your mind keeps telling
you something different.
It's kind of hard.
- You still have contact with your family?
- Somewhat. I haven't
been lately, but I was
the majority of the time
I've been down here.
- How was your relationship with them?
Were your parents accepting of you?
- They tried, but it was hard for them.
It was part of the reason
why I came down here.
But I had to learn that it's not all them,
because we're always
stuck in our own feelings
that we don't recognize that
hey, these people gave
birth to something and now
that person's grown a little
bit and is telling them
they're something different
and that's hard for-
We don't realize that because we're going
through it ourselves.
So they're hard.
They're both sides of the spectrum.
One's a biker hillbilly
from Kentucky and the other
one's a Catholic city girl.
So surprisingly they tried but it was hard
for them to accept because
they're so old school.
- Are drugs, a part of your life?
- Not at the beginning
because I was a real bad
alcoholic when I came out here
and then I was sober.
But in the last two years, yes.
- You started using what?
- Meth.
It's just kind of out on a limb.
I just started using it.
And it's just been a pretty
bad habit ever since.
- Well, what does crystal meth do for you?
- Honestly as a social
thing, because I've always
been so introverted and
kind of hurted it over that.
Another thing about Skid
Row is there's always
so many sides of a whole
big spectrum, a variety
of people, but the most of
us have an issue that's been
pointed out or labeled.
And, but it that's, what's
great about Skid Row is
it's a variety and it
doesn't matter who you are.
You'll be, you'll fit in some kind of-
- There there's everything here.
You've got gang members,
you've got transgenders,
you've got sex workers,
you've got drug addicts.
- It's vernic to everything.
- Pedophiles.
- Yeah, virtually.
- Murders.
- Yeah. You got to watch all that.
That's why kind of like
a network, almost people
that you know, you kind
of have to stick together
with that kind of thing
to let each other in
on a heads up on who's
the next new person or.
- What's been the hardest
part of your life?
- Hardest part?
- Yeah.
- When you're at home with your family
or since you've been on the street?
- I believe actually
the street has not been as bad
as say preteens and teens.
- It must've been a hard time.
- And right after, cause I wasn't much
aware of being trans, or what trans was.
I just knew what I was going through.
And so it was hard for me to
adjust and grow in that aspect
until I came out here and
just came out here and it just
kinda just happened just
by living it instead of
out constantly pondering or being-
- What was the best time of your life?
- Best time?
Coming out here, to Skid Row.
It was the worst situation but
best change and best growth
that I've ever, and glimmer
of hope that I've ever seen.
I guess we all reach first a
star but some of us don't seem
to be able to even have
a hand close to it.
And the closest I came to
one coming out of here.
- Interesting.
What kind of things have you seen
since you've been out here in Skid Row?
- Oh, a lot.
- Or can you give me an example?
- That's the hardest thing
in the world is I have
to turn the other cheek
when you want to stand up
or stick up for somebody.
I've seen a trans female
to male lesbian be beat up
and I couldn't do anything about it.
I saw her like months later and she said
it's a good thing you didn't cause,
she's stubborn apparently.
And she didn't want to
move out of her spot.
And she stood up for herself,
like I guess like six
eight people beat her.
I've seen tent hoppers, so
they call, tent hoppers.
There's so many things.
- But what's a, what's a tent hopper.
- Just a female that hops tent to tent
for supplies or whatever to-
- Drugs?
- Yeah. Drugs. Just to
have a place to stay
or get cleaned up or just simple stuff.
It saddens me because one I'm nosy but two
I can't see going that low.
I think what we have to share
with somebody in that
intimacy is a little bit
wears a whole lot more than that.
But I seen all kinds of stuff.
You know, seen people stabbed,
seen people jump off the roof.
I just recently had a friend
that jumped off the roof,
well not the roof, the
railing in my building.
He was a close friend of mine.
He was supposed to be
there meeting me actually
and he died instantly.
Some people like their
minds get so full of stuff
I think they can't take it anymore.
I've came really close to it, I believe.
But I just don't have the total guts to go
to a hundred percent.
I don't know.
- What do you think the biggest issue is
for all these people down here?
Would you say it's drugs?
Would you say it's mental
health, what would you say?
- It's a variety.
I think a lot come down here
because of the resources,
and kind of get stuck.
A lot of them-
- Freedom and the lack of
responsibility and all that?
- Yeah exactly.
Complacent. A lot is mental
illness I believe and the drugs.
And like you said, the easy life.
A lot like me, come down here
and they find a common
ground for themselves.
It's hard to say how that happens
or what I'm talking about.
But like when I came
out here, I didn't have,
I was so oppressed, you
know, by family by my past
and we came out here
and I found a more foundation for myself.
I came more in lined,
when people used to say
that I had no awareness
what they meant, but I was
I became more aligned
and that's very significant
personally to one person.
It gives you that freedom,
majority of the time.
- Where do you see your
life going from here?
- Coming from here?
I used his say being a star
but reality is we don't
know how that will work.
- When you say be a star and
you're hoping to be an actor?
- I came out here to dance.
Then I started looking
for extras, extra work,
some kind of gig, maybe modeling or dance
or acting like you said
- How old are you now?
- I'm 29.
- You're what?
- 29.
And you?
- I think I'm old enough
to be your grandfather.
- What are your goals at
this point in your life?
Do you have a goal
or are you just trying
to survive at this point?
- That's the problem.
The last two years the things
I've been through with people
and spiritually, my drive is not there.
The mindset, but the drive
is kind of like depleted
and actually I've met a new man.
I was with one for nine years,
but that didn't work out and he's
I want to say wishy-washy
but it's not wishy-washy.
He's like me, kinda like keeps a wall up
but I didn't expect expectations
to grow, but now I do.
I expect something hopefully with him.
We all want to be rich.
I want to be able to live
somewhat of a lavish life someday.
Cause I've never had that.
- All right, J.
It's nice seeing you again.
Thank you for talking with me
and good luck with wherever
your life goes from here.
- Thank you.